I've seen some people talking about
things they were during their decree and
it's usually things like time management
or learning to take opportunities as
they come and how to manage doing lots
of different things and whether those
are or not true for my own experience I
wanted to talk about some things that
I've literally learned during my time as
a physics student I'm gonna start by
talking about relativistic
electromagnetism
so electromagnetism is basically
electricity in the movement of charges
and you learn about this at high school
and sort of a fundamental level but not
about how relativity comes into it so
relativity or the special theory of
relativity was one of Ernst inés ideas
and half of it is kind of well knowing
and that is time dilation so if you are
moving close to the speed of light time
will actually slow down for you now
there's a second part to this and that
is length contraction so for an object
moving at a high speed close to the
speed of light that don't be observer
moving at that speed will see lengths to
be shorter than sort of the true length
and this is known as length contraction
or also Lorentz contraction so if you
know a little bit about electromagnetism
you know that you've got charges moving
at really high speeds and actually it
kind of makes sense that relativity
would come into it because you're moving
near the speed of light to think about
this imagine that we have a wire with
positive charges moving to the right and
negative charges moving to the left
they're moving with equal and opposite
speed to an observer that's stationary
next to the wire the positive and
negative charges would essentially
cancel each other out and there would be
no net electrostatic force if instead
you are limping at this wire and you're
moving to the right
high speed then relativity is actually
going to change the situation for your
point of view so the positive charges
that are moving in the same direction as
you but it was a slightly higher speed
than you are they will now appear to be
moving a bit slower than the negative
charges which are meaning to the left
and sort of zooming out of frame behind
you if you consider length contraction
it will actually contract the space
between these negative charges meaning
that in the wire you are observing they
will seem like there is more negative
charges than there are positive leading
to a net negative charge and an electric
force generated by the wire affecting
you the observer in fact by looking at
the wireless way and doing some
mathematical derivations of what that
electric force would be you get an
answer that's consistent with sort of
the classical view of
dynamics and also you generate the need
for magnetism and this whole idea really
links together
electricity magnetism and relativity in
a way where you see that all three of
the ideas are really well linked
together
Einstein not only worked on special
relativity time dilation and length
contraction but on a more general form
which is called general relativity and
one of the key ideas behind general
relativity this called
now this states that an observer can't
tell the difference between standing on
under a gravitational field being inside
an accelerating box what this is really
saying is imagine you're in an elevator
or a box on earth and you drop an object
well it will go down to the ground and
it will accelerate at 9.8 meters per
second that's sort of the force of
gravity pulling its mass downwards then
instead imagine you are in the same box
that you're flying off into space and
you're not being acted on by any
gravitational forces because you're far
enough away from any of the planets or
other messes and you drop the same
object well you also see it go down and
you'll see it go down at the rate that
your spaceship is accelerating you and
if that rate is 9.8 years the second we
truly won't be able to tell the
difference between being on earth and
being in the spaceship if there were no
windows on these boxes you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference
thinking like this means that gravity is
not just a force but a distortion in
space and time in freefall
physics are the same as if there was no
gravity or those two ideas kind of
relate to theoretical physics they're
both kind of about relativity in a way
and the third thing that comes to mind
when I think of cool things I learned
during my degree and well there's lots
of them I just picked three that came to
mind for this video the third idea would
be from PD it's the metaphysics of
material science and it's the idea that
well there are more phases of matter
than the ones you hear about every day
so you know that there are solid liquid
gas and plasma as he four fundamental
states of metal but within the solid
state there are multiple phases these
phases relate to how the atoms are
structured within the crystalline solid
for example solid iron has a body
centered cubic structure at a reasonably
low temperature this means that the
internal structures of the iron atoms
can be described as like a cube with one
atom in the sea
the key and the rest in the corners iron
then becomes face centered cubic
structure at higher temperatures meaning
that there's now an atom at the center
of each of the phases ice has 15 knowin
kinds of crystalline structures have a
solid and the way that you can sort of
change from materials between these
phases is I apply pressure changing the
temperature and you're essentially
changing that internal structure the
research group that I'm currently a part
of does a lot of work into this applying
huge pressures to materials to find you
something phases and these new phases
have different properties for things
like semiconductors or other areas where
you want to sort of to exploit the
properties of materials then changing
their phases and he able to manipulate
this it's really important to understand